[Music]
the mutos are the first sky dude since
monster x from godzilla final wars
that was seen in the movie screens and
the murders are godzilla's first
completely original opponents that he
faced since the titanosaurus that
appeared in terror of mecca godzilla
every other enemy of godzilla has fought
since then are either enemies he has
fought before
or their clones of him or are derived
from him or based on an existing monster
so legendary went on full creative for
the muto designs and they were a success
as they instantly became fan favorites
but since legendary went
awol with their life cycle information
we mineke will present a whole new
picture
on this missing part conforming to the
facts as best
as we could without alienating a
creature that is already very mysterious
so what do we know about the mutos we
have seen four of them till now
including the one in the comics godzilla
aftershock so there's the male muto
the female muto the muto prime and
lastly barbara
the queen muto and all along the way we
got to see the spores of these tyrants
and the chrysalis that they were
cocooned in
as well as miniature female mutos in
many scenes of godzilla 2014 in the
desert
in san francisco as they were encased in
soft eggs inside a female
and were laid in a large hole so the
question arises if they were laid as
eggs so then why did the other two come
from spores
and why were all four of these mutos so
very different from each other
so check this theory out stage 1 spores
they are the first stage of the muto
life process and like a wasp that lays
its
eggs its parasitoid eggs inside another
animal the muto prime injects them
inside the body of a member of godzilla
species
which we now know has a name that is
daegon like the cthulhu mythos deity
so these spores slowly and steadily
drain the titan's radioactive blood and
grow in size
these two spores in fact had been
dormant for thousands of years
and things suddenly changed in 1999 when
they hatched
giving way to the second stage of their
life cycle
stage two the larva the two spores give
rise to two hatchlings or lava
and both of them have a very different
sex that is a male and a female of
course
the male lava digs its way out from the
philippines and could already swim
therefore heading towards the nearest
radiation source which is the janjira
nuclear power plant in japan
the female spore however was still
dormant and was taken by the us military
to the yukar mountain nuclear waste
depository in nevada
so therefore the reason why we didn't
see the female lava was that
when she hatched she was already in the
best nursery humans could provide for
her
so both of them cocooned themselves and
started to mature to their adult stages
stage 3 chrysalis so both of them
started to cocoon themselves and all the
while slowly feeding on the radiation
that was present on the site
the chrysalis of the female wasn't seen
in the movie but the male's chrysalis
was very clear
it was gigantic in size and was somehow
cone-shaped
but the end was curved inwards and the
outer layer seems to look like an
exoskeleton with spikes and ribs that
had
translucent segments which were lit up
red from time to time due to excess
energy and the male's bioluminescence
the chrysalis was hot and looked like a
hellish gateway for which
a monster would come out which it did
stage 4 the female and male adult stages
the mutos bodies were covered in an
iridescent metallic greyish black
exoskeleton they have orangey red eyes
narrowly shaped eyes
as the species demutoes are sexually
dimorphic as there
are several notable differences between
the males and females
the male muto has two pairs of pholums
and a smaller pair on her abdomen
and two high limbs and is much bigger
than a male muto standing nearly twice
the height of the male
and being almost as tall as godzilla
himself the male muto is similar in
appearance except that he is much
smaller
with a more nimble body and one of the
two volumes
had been modified into his wings which
are long pointed and membranous
similar to those of a pterosaur both of
them possess long slender somewhat
deer like hind limbs with flat broad
feet ending in two hoof
like toes and they went to san francisco
to mate and lay their eggs
stage five the queen younglings in the
movie we could see inside the muto nest
and then after the female lays her eggs
there is this weird sap like substance
coming out from the numerous egg sacs
that might probably be the protective
layer now after the muto eggs are nested
they begin to form into various worm or
spider-like creatures
now keep in mind that they are totally
different from the spores
laid by the muto prime so there wrapped
around the nuclear missile they would
feed on the radiation and then
they would reach a state of sexual
maturity and this is our theory
they would develop into a new queen muto
that have the ability to insert spores
into other titans
stage 6 the queen muto muto 3 referred
to as the queen murder looks slightly
different in appearance to the female
unlike her deceased skin the queen mutos
exoskeleton is more gray color
instead of black her body is covered in
scars from past battles
and she is also bigger in size than both
the other two and with spiky protrusions
on her back
it would seem that she is similar to the
female but on another level of the life
cycle which could lead
up to her developing into the next muto
prime
so here is another one of our theories
she could also possess the ability to
inject spores
into other tyrants like the prime the
official novelization describes her as a
six-legged monster although she
possesses 8 limbs
in the movie and stage 7 the muto prime
this penultimate stage is nearly
identical to the two females but it has
a hardened outer shell with razor sharp
back spires on it
large orange glowing volumes as well as
several smaller pairs of volumes on her
chest
with more defined jaws along with larger
mandibles unlike the other two prime
walks on four legs instead of six
or eight as it appears that some limbs
were fused during the process of
metamorph forces
which would mean that the queen muta
will have another stage
or a metamorphosis or another cocoon
stage that would lead
to it hatching into a muto prime so the
meteor prime was much larger than dagon
and godzilla in 2014
himself and she had the ability to
infect other titans with her spores
which would lead
up to the next generation of the life
cycle she could very well be
a very ancient form of the queen muto
and that has lived for
millions of years and just like how
godzilla could grow in size and have
bigger dorsal blades
she too could slowly change in
appearance over time
and so with that we come to the end of
this video about the life cycle of the
mutos and hope you guys liked it
if you have another theory then put it
down in the comment section
anyways thanks guys subscribe and hit
the notification bell for
regular updates and all that fun